[Música]
no primeiro contato com o circo
talvez não tenha sido tão mágico quando
foi pra vocês e para a maioria das
pessoas
pra mim foi meio traumático eu lembro
que tinha 56 anos e eu estava numa festa
infantil estava sentado e do nada eu
virei um palhaço atrás de mim e me deu
um susto tão grande que me traumatizou
desde então não queria saber de palhaço
não queria saber de de circo de nada
disso
até que foi passando o templo uma tia
minha e me mostraram que era só uma
pessoa maquiada e etc mas acho que isso
meio que repercutiu na minha vida eu fui
deixando o circo mais pra depois dentro
de todas as outras atividades de arte
que eu fiz desde que me entendo por
gente eu me envolvi com arte sempre fiz
art
eu comecei com o teatro me formei em
atom trabalhei dirige o espetáculo atuei
mas parecia que não me completava
parecia que eu precisava de mais
ali não era suficiente pra mim e aí fui
pra dança trabalha com dança
contemporânea também fiz dança popular
viajei dançando teve a companhia de
dança coreografia do espetáculo um monte
de coisa mas também não me completava
parecia que faltava alguma coisa nesse
meio tempo eu tive contato com o tecido
acrobático que é uma modalidade do circo
da parte do aéreo aquele pano que as
pessoas dessem rolando
eu tive a oportunidade de fazer um curso
com o grupo da bahia um curso mágico
eles montaram o antigo circo da cidade
ea gente pode experimentar todo o
universo do circo desde aéreo acrobacia
de solo com torção monociclo e tudo e
naquele momento o tecido me pegou e de
lá pra cá são 13 anos como professor de
circo vem de circo trabalhando com circo
e naquele momento eu tive uma grande
oportunidade
eu fiz a oficina e logo depois de fazer
um curso de formação de instrutor da
linha daquela oficina eu passei
a me tornar instrutor e viver de circo
como vivo até hoje
isso me deu um estalo muito grande eu
percebi que tudo na minha vida tinha
sido a oportunidade
minha formação técnica em teatro foi com
bolsa de estudo
minha graduação também com bolsa minha
pós-graduação também com o bolso
minha formação técnica em produção
cultural agora também com a oportunidade
e eu disse não não pode como assim uma
pessoa ter tanta oportunidade assim não
fazer nada com isso
nesse momento eu percebi a gente precisa
fazer alguma coisa para retribuir
eu preciso retribuir toda oportunidade
que eu tive foi quando eu juntei com os
amigos meus que trabalhavam juntos na
mesma escola na época e montamos o que
foi o embrião do que hoje é o circo está
na rua
foi um núcleo de formação artística mas
abriu seleção para 20 jovens e estes
jovens receberam aulas de teatro de
dança e de circo gratuitamente
deu muito certo mas conseguimos fazer
outras opções entre outras pessoas
começamos a trabalhar na cidade fazer
parte do calendário cultural da cidade
participando com o teatro com dança com
um circo mas o circo começou a ficar
muito forte
nós éramos a representação de circo da
cidade até que nós fomos convidados para
um evento evento badaladíssimo que é um
festival br 135 ea gente nossa
a gente foi convidado para recepcionar o
br sempre decide não para tudo que
também estamos na fita estamos fazendo
certo lá foi muito engraçado porque nós
nos preparamos todos pra fazer uma bela
recepção e vamos lá vamos mostrar que a
gente sabe fazer ea gente não conseguiu
recepcionar as pessoas não deixaram a
gente recepcionar as pessoas queriam
aprender circo
as pessoas queriam fazer elas tomavam os
malabares das nossas mãos e queriam que
a gente ensinasse para elas até que uma
pessoa que estava lá
neste evento que a fernandinha marx
hoje está comigo no projeto e é uma das
pessoas que eu mais confio dentro do
trabalho chegou e me perguntou como é
que fazia pra aprender que ela queria
estar junto com a gente que ela queria
fazer parte disso de supetão no estalo
eu disse amanhã vai ter um treino de
circo aberto e gratuito
lá na praça nauro machado era domingo a
recepção à noite e eu disse segunda vai
ter amanhã vai ter pode lá que seis
horas a gente vai estar lá e teve e ela
foi
e de lá pra cá são quase quatro anos de
ocupação e resistência naquele espaço
isso me mostrou que um contato que é tão
mínimo uma pergunta de uma desconhecida
que juntou duas vontades a minha a dela
e mais vontades das outras pessoas que
também queriam aprender conseguiu esse
pequeno contato fazer uma história tão
grande acontecer
os cinco se tornou algo tão grande tão
maior do que eu então maior do que as
pessoas que fazem parte dele que a gente
não tem noção do que a gente alcança
conselho está na rua porque é uma força
coletiva é uma força que não depende de
mim não parte só de mim ela é de todas
as pessoas que acreditam que juntas
podem fazer alguma coisa e isso se
tornou tão grande isso moveu tanta gente
isso moveu muitas pessoas isso moveu
muitos coletivos isso moveu muitas
parcerias isso moveu muitas
oportunidades isso moveu muitas
fronteiras
isso me moveu isso me mexeu a ponto de
eu receber um agradecimento de uma
pessoa que eu não esperava
tinha um rapaz que freqüentava os está
na rua toda segunda feira ele estava lá
ele não treinava circo ele só estava lá
eu já conhecia ele de vista pelo pv como
morador do centro histórico
já tinha visto antes
e ele chegou até mim e disse odone
já sabendo o nome já doni muito obrigado
pelo que tu fazes aqui toda segunda
feira
eu pensava que ele ia pedir alguma coisa
sem lá e ele chegou pra mim e disse
muito obrigado pelo que tu fazes aqui
toda segunda-feira e eu fiquei desarmado
disse poxa massa mas como assim o que o
que é isso pra ti e ele disse que a
segunda feira era o único dia que ele
não queria se drogar no river era o
único dia que ele não queria beber e
dormir na sarjeta bêbado era o único dia
que ele não queria brigar com ninguém
era o único dia que ele se sentia bem e
se sentia parte daquele lugar
mesmo enfrentando há anos e todos os
dias
a segunda feira era o único dia que ele
sentia parte daquele espaço pra mim foi
tudo ouvir isso não tenha conhecimento
maior pra gente que faz isso que
acredita nisso é grande demais é imenso
é é é surreal a ponto da gente
participar de uma oficina com o grupo do
rio de janeiro por exemplo e e ao final
da oficina uma oficina de perna de pau e
ao final da oficina os professores
chegarem para a gente dizer em tomar que
três pernas de pau pra vocês novinhas
porque eu conheço o trabalho de vocês há
muito tempo a companhia nas redes
sociais acredita no que vocês fazem me
reconheço o trabalho de vocês
então a minha forma de ajudar é s aqui a
gente não esperava a gente não sabia que
se quer ele não conhecia a ponto de a
senhora que vem de lá no rever todo dia
lá com o soropositivo é vendendo água
bebida não deixa eu pagar quando eu
quero comprar alguma coisa a não aceita
porque ela disse pra mim que na
segunda-feira não vendia
nada e agora ela vende muito ea única
forma dela que ela pode me retribuir
essa me dando uma água de graça
isso me enche
isso me enche muito e isso me enche por
que comigo
o circo completou um vazio o circo
preencher um vazio em mim eu já atuei
já trabalhei como eu falei inicialmente
trabalha com dança o teatro com circo me
apresentei
eu era dos palcos minha vida era o palco
adorava estar no palco eu adorava essa
sensação aqui e se esse clima pra mim é
maravilhoso
só que eu tive que sair porque eu me
machuquei tive uma lesão na coluna tem
uma hérnia de disco e de lá pra cá foram
seis seis tentativas de voltar à ativa
de voltar a treinar mas nunca dar nunca
dá porque a dor é muito grande porque
fica muito tempo em pé dói ficar muito
tempo sentado dói e se alongar muito dói
fazer muito exercício dói e eu tive que
sair do lugar que eu amava
isso deixa um vazio um vazio imenso
imenso que eu só vi completar eu só vi
encher
quando eu entendi o que o circo na rua
fez na minha vida
a ponto de o perceber que eu podia
deixar esse lugar de luz de holofotes e
deixar outras pessoas passarem a estar
nesse lugar
isso me encheu isso me enche e isso me
faz acreditar que nós estamos no caminho
certo que o circo está na rua é esse
lugar que vocês aí podem ocupar da luz
dos holofotes
e as formas não são pra mim as formas
jamais poderiam ser só pra mim porque eu
sou um meia articulador dentro desse
processo todo eu acho que eu fui só
alguém que tive a sorte de ter a idéia
mas acho que não na fruição do universo
e até lá só foi o sortudo de detido um
gatilho mas à coletividade é a palavra
chave é a palavra forte
é o que representa nós do centro está na
rua e eu queria apresentar para vocês
essa equipe
essas pessoas são o garante é artemis
lisboa igual viegas ana raquel farias o
em albuquerque no lago fila mais isso
além de morais letícia souza
raulzito neste monteiro
fernandinha martin samuel chaves ana
beatriz chaves e antônio carlos
[Aplausos]
é para lembrar obrigado gente é para
lembrar que eu não o culpo esse lugar
mas sozinho e é ótimo quando a gente não
há culpa esse lugar de luis sozinho
quando a gente dá espaço pode vir venha
estejam na loja junto comigo façam parte
disso junto comigo é isso gente
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]